donc nous allons entamer les
explications de vote cinq minutes par
orateur
madame la parole est à madame Béatrice
Bellamy pour le groupe horizon
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues
déjà à travers le monde des milliers de
sportifs ils pensent matin midi et soir
déjà ils en rêvent et en cauchemar de
parfois il regarde vers 2024 et vers
Paris avec ce mélange d'impatience et
d'appréhension propre au challenge d'une
vie car oui l'horizon des JO se
rapproche il se dresse devant nous comme
un défi à la nation tout entière c'est
une épreuve que nous devons
collectivement surmonter nous en avons
la détermination nous en avons la
volonté nous devons encore susciter
l'enthousiasme de nos concitoyens le
groupe Horizon est apparenté et
convaincu des vertus sportives
solidaires économiques
urbanistique et durable et des Jeux
Olympiques que notre pays organise les
JO 2024 doivent être une réussite non
parce que le succès serait un but en soi
mais surtout car il est le moyen de
viser plus haut de viser un héritage qui
dépasse nos générations aussi mes chers
collègues nous aurions grand tort aux
yeux des Français et du monde de faire
des JO un objet de querelle partisane et
de conflits politiciens nous avons œuvré
efficacement et j'ose dire sereinement à
ce texte il permet de compléter la loi
de 2018 et Marc une étape supplémentaire
vers le vendredi 26 juillet 2024 en
matière d'accès aux soins d'abord avec
l'ouverture d'une polyclinique pour
assurer une offre de soins de premiers
secours aux athlètes aux membres des
délégations et aux personnes accréditées
les articles 4 et 5 prévoit une mise en
conformité de notre droit national avec
le code mondial antidopage ainsi que des
autorisations à des analyses génétiques
une homologation des peines applicables
en Nouvelle-Calédonie
ce texte porte des mesures essentielles
en matière de sécurité et c'est un enjeu
incontournable pour accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions près de 15000
athlètes athlètes et des centaines de
milliers de spectateurs durant cet
événement exceptionnel la sécurité n'est
pas une option ni je ne sais quelle
ballon d'essai c'est une obligation de
résultats c'est une question de
responsabilité collective les députés
horizons soutiennent la compétence
élargée du préfet de police de Paris
l'expérimentation de la vidéo
surveillance intelligente
l'élargissement du champ des personnes
pouvant faire l'objet d'une enquête
administrative
ce texte instaure également des
dispositions relatives à la publicité
notamment l'article 14 dont j'ai été
rapporteur il transpose les dispositions
du contrat de ville haute et du CIO dans
notre droit national il permet de
déroger aux interdictions de publicité
dans le cadre du relais de la flamme et
autorise l'installation d'un compte à
rebours à Paris je me réjouis de ce
projet de loi prévoit la remise au
Parlement d'un rapport il aura pour
effet
d'évaluer l'organisation le coût et
l'héritage des jeux mais aussi l'accueil
et la qualité de sportifs de vie des
sportifs et spectateurs en situation de
handicap ce rapport permettra de
parfaire l'information du Parlement
avant celui que la Cour des comptes
rendra à l'automne 2026
j'ai souhaité que ce texte fasse mention
de la Coupe du monde de rugby dans cette
répétition de la rentrée 2023 nous
pourrons voir à l'oeuvre un certain
nombre de dispositifs enfin nous
permettons l'ouverture de certains
commerces le dimanche autour des sites
de compétition ou encore
l'expérimentation d'autorisation de
stationnement pour transporter les pour
développer pardon les transports de
personnes à mobilité réduite dans
l'agglomération parisienne
à l'issue de l'étude de ce texte par
notre assemblée je salue l'ensemble de
mes collègues rapporteurs nous pensons
que nous avons construit un texte
équilibré reflet de l'exigence
collective que les JO commandent si les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques sont la
fête des athlètes s'il suscite
l'engouement chez nos compatriotes s'ils
sont un moment unique vécu en toute
sécurité s'ils permettent notre
rayonnement national alors la France
aura réussi ses JO
les députés horizons le souhaitent
ardemment et c'est pour l'ensemble de
ces raisons que mon groupe votera en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à présent à Madame Sandra
rogol pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur le texte sur
lequel nous sommes amenés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans la
droite ligne de l'actuel politique du
gouvernement et en particulier celle du
ministère de l'intérieur des effets de
manche sans effets réel pour assurer la
sûreté des personnes pourtant un droit
fondamental défini par la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme des manifestations
contre votre indigne réforme des
retraites à celles pour que l'eau reste
un bien commun à Sainte Soline une même
stratégie de l'image de la force au
détriment de la sécurité des personnes
qu'il s'agisse des agents sur le terrain
ou des manifestants et des manifestants
et là soutenu par l'extrême droite vous
proposez d'aller encore plus loin en
dotant le pays de moyen de traquer par
une surveillance à analyse biométrique
les personnes de votre choix évidemment
ce sera plus rapide pour retrouver les
membres des soulèvements de la Terre
mais dans tous les cas de figure ça
restera une traque a postériori puisque
votre obsession techno solutionniste je
parle de celle de ce gouvernement et de
ses soutiens même s'ils sont extrêmement
à ma droite ne propose que cela agir à
posteriori sans protéger sans prévenir
sans empêcher plus vite plus haut plus
fort ensemble oui certes mais pour aller
plus vite dans la répression plus haut
dans le déni et plus fort dans la
surveillance généralisée de la
population
je vois que j'aime fan club à mon
extrême droite l'article cède qui
déploie la vidéo surveillance par
algorithme bien au-delà des seuls jeux
et pour tous types de manifestation
prendre tout son sens dans l'actualité
qui est la nôtre alors que de très
nombreuses et diverses organisations ont
alerté sur les dangers de cet article
pour les droits et libertés qu'il
s'agisse de la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme de la Quadrature du Net ou du
Conseil national des barreaux pour ne
citer que vous avez choisi la surdité et
persister à défendre dans la mise en
place d'une technologie qui traitera les
données comportementales de millions de
personnes sans les en informer en
conservant les images en formation sur
elle jusqu'à un an et demi au mépris des
règles de protection des données
européennes et du droit commun on est
pris surtout du mot liberté que ce
gouvernement et ses soutiens importants
instrumentalisés le territoire français
pourrait donc demain être couvert de
caméra dotées d'algorithmes en mesure
d'identifier des comportements anormaux
alors on en a beaucoup parlé un de ces
fameux comportements anormaux mais on
n'a jamais obtenu de définition
juridique valable qu'est-ce que ça
signifie un comportement normal il se
définit par rapport à quelle normalité
comment les agents les juges vont
quantifier la quantité de normalité
suffisante pour être tolérable ou non
quelle base juridique à ce flou rien du
tout et en réponse silence radio
circuler
ce qui est certain de c'est qu'à vos
yeux ce ne sont certainement pas les
écologistes qui rentrent dans la case de
votre normalité et je m'en réjouis vous
avez donc choisi de continuer votre
travail de SAP de leur mobilisation et
actions à ces écologistes par le
truchement de l'article 12 vous ciblez
la particulièrement l'activisme de la
jeunesse vous savez celle qui hurlent la
longueur de temps aux dirigeants de ce
monde et au gouvernement comment
osez-vous rester inactif face à l'avenir
qui nous attend celle qui hurle a
commencé par à contre ceux qui dirigent
à commencer par celui qui dirige la
France qui refuse d'agir et qui est
toujours plus condamné pour une action
climatique ce silence elle le vit tous
les jours cette jeunesse et là en plus
elle aura la répression augmentée cette
jeunesse c'est celle qui était présente
en masse à Sainte-Soline ce week-end que
vous tentez de diviser en choisissant
les gentils et les autres et à laquelle
vous avez répondu par plus de 4000
grenades produisant plus de 200 blessés
dont deux au pronostic vital engagés
toujours alors je vous parle
par cet article rédigez contre eux ces
jeunes qui se battent pour le droit en
avenir peut-être que vous ça nous
intéresse pas mais eux et nous ça nous
intéresse vous avez donc rédigé cet
article contre l'esprit de l'olympisme
et contre l'histoire du sport vous
faites le choix de cibler toute
possibilité de dimension politique au
jeu et plus largement la dimension
politique du sport puisque ces mesures
resteront de manière définitive et non
pas transitoire dans le code des sports
pourtant le sport est politique
rappelez-vous les JO de Mexico on en a
déjà parlé rappelez-vous aussi Catherine
switer si en 67 elle n'avait pas décidé
de provoquer la société de faire un acte
inacceptable en particulier en tant que
femme au marathon de Boston vous notez
que la réponse a été la même que la
vôtre un la brutalité à sa participation
et bien si elle n'avait pas été là si
elle n'avait pas provoqué cette
brutalité le sport féminin n'aurait pas
été la même à côté de ces mesures
sécurité ce texte ne contient rien sur
le sport il aurait pu bâtir un héritage
pour les populations locales tenir ses
promesses sur le sport pour tous
l'écologie l'accessibilité mais non rien
le seul héritage que laisseront ces jeux
ce sont des maladies chroniques aussi
sans enfant du groupe scolaire Anatole
France de Pleyel exposé aux particules
fines ou à l'école Louis Lumière qui se
voit transporter de lieu en lieu ce
texte est donc le symbole de la vision
de ce gouvernement une vision contraire
à la nôtre qui pense sont à l'avenir et
aux personnes nous voterons donc contre
aider demain merci je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane peu du
groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024
sont à la fois une immense chance et une
immense responsabilité pour notre pays
pendant un mois de Paris à Marseille de
Saint-Denis à Tahiti des milliers
d'athlètes vont nous procurer toutes
sortes d'émotions le sport de haut
niveau est une source de communion une
fabrique de souvenirs collectifs il
suscite les vocations et un site les
enfants à la pratique sportive le sport
est un fait socialement et doit être
traité comme tel par nos politiques
publiques pourtant le sport est de plus
en plus soumis au consumérisme avec le
risque d'une dénaturation profonde des
valeurs dont il est porteur celle de
l'esprit d'équipe du fair-play de la
solidarité de l'excellence de l'égalité
devant l'épreuve du respect et de
l'amitié des valeurs de l'olympisme et
la quintessence mais des valeurs qui
sont souvent trop souvent écrasés par le
poids de l'argent
c'est pourquoi et en prenant appui sur
ces jeux il faudra bien dans notre pays
ouvrir ce chantier et libérer le sport
des logiques de l'argent roi qui
l'asphyxie c'est donc dans cet état
d'esprit profondément favorable aux Jeux
Olympiques que les députés du groupe GDR
ont abordé ce texte et c'est parce que
nous sommes profondément investis dans
leur réussite que nous avons soutenu
plusieurs articles qui nous apparaissent
nécessaires à l'organisation des
épreuves je connais les attentes et les
espoirs des habitants de mon département
de la Seine-Saint-Denis qui accueillera
80% des infrastructures construites pour
ces jeux comme autant d'atouts pour
l'avenir de ce département mais
attention la période que nous vivons
soulève beaucoup d'inquiétudes comment
construire des jeux de concorde dans un
pays que l'on a tant fracturé
le climat d'extrême tension que le
gouvernement a suscité dans le pays avec
sa réforme des retraites et l'exact
opposé de ce que les jeux doivent
produire un pays uni par une idée
rassemblée sur un projet et une réussite
commune comment réussir ses jeux sans en
faire un grand moment populaire sans la
ferveur de cette foule que le Président
de la République
s'acharne tant à mépriser madame la
ministre je vous le dis avec gravité la
situation actuelle aura des conséquences
sur la réussite des jeux si l'exécutif
continue dans cette voie
après quatre jours de débat et plus de
500 amendements étudiés les députés
communistes et le groupe Zr souligne les
améliorations du texte notamment celle
qui en cas de plus strictement dans le
temps certains dispositifs nous saluons
ainsi l'esprit d'écoute des rapporteurs
et de la ministre il reste cependant
pour nous d'importants motifs
d'opposition que j'avais déjà qualifié
de véritables chevals législatives
l'expérimentation de la vidéo
surveillance algorithmique est une ligne
rouge et inesstiel à l'organisation de
ces jeux cet article vient détourner
inutilement de son objet en précipitant
le recours à cette technologie qui sera
à n'en pas douter pérennisé à la suite
des jeux par une loi une énième loi
sécurité il en est de même concernant
l'article flexibilisant encore un peu
plus l'ouverture des commerces le
dimanche des dispositifs existent déjà
pourquoi aller encore plus loin si ce
n'est pour préparer la fin défin du
repos dominical et pourquoi n'avoir
consulté ni les acteurs de la Charte
sociale des jeux ni les organisations
syndicales alors oui même si un
amendement de mon groupe vient mieux
encadrer dans le temps cette possibilité
d'ouverture sur décision du préfet le
signal envoyé est néanmoins mauvais nous
avons durant les débats exprimés aussi
nos réticences face aux dispositions
renforçant encore la répression dans les
stades nous alertons une nouvelle fois
sur la méthode de construction des
mesures relatives au supporterisme sans
associer l'installation nationale du
support terrestre enfin je souhaite
saluer le travail mener avec les députés
de Polynésie en particulier avec le
président broterson pour la rédaction de
l'article 5 respectueuse de la
souveraineté de la Polynésie tout en
permettant aux dispositions antidopage
de s'appliquer pleinement sur le
territoire ce trait d'action traduit le
dialogue efficace qu'il s'est menait
avec les autorités gouvernementales
en faveur de son territoire aussi pour
toutes ces raisons les députés
communistes et du groupe GDR
s'absiendront sur ce texte et il
continueront leur travail en faveur de
la réussite des jeux
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
nejlaine pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur remet chers
collègues pour la première fois depuis
100 ans la France va accueillir les Jeux
olympiques et parlympique comme beaucoup
de nos concitoyens notre groupe attend
ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
souhaite qu'il se dérouillent dans les
meilleurs conditions je salue
l'investissement des prêts de 70
collectivités territoriales hautes tant
sur le continent quand outremer il est
nécessaire que les retombées de ces jeux
soient bénéfiques au-delà de la région
parisienne alors qu'elle dispose déjà
des infrastructures sportives de
transport et d'hébergement les plus
importantes de notre pays
aux enjeux économiques et aux risques en
matière de sécurité et de transport ces
risques doivent impérativement se
dérouler dans le meilleur conditions
c'est également notre image celle de la
France qui sera mondialement reflété au
travers de ces jeux le travail à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat sur ce
texte a parmi a permis l'atteinte d'un
équilibre entre la sécurisation des jeux
et la préservation de nos droits et de
nos libertés individuelles ce projet de
loi dotent l'état de moyen de sécurité
innovants et à la hauteur des enjeux
comme l'expérimentation de la vidéo
surveillance intelligente pour les
manifestations avec des caméras
augmentés les contrôles avec scanner
corporel la mise en place de billets
infalsifiables l'automatisation la peine
d'interdiction de stade en cas de délit
je souhaite revenir sur l'article 7 qui
prévoit à titre expérimental le recours
à des traitements algorithmiques
permettant d'identifier à partir
d'images certains événements présentant
des risques pour la sécurité des
personnes lors des manifestations
concrètement de manière inédite pour des
fins de sécurité il permet le recours à
l'intelligence artificielle pour traiter
les images captées par vidéoprotection
ou caméra d'aéronef à l'occasion de
manifestations récréatives sportives ou
culturelles d'ampleur particulièrement
exposé à des risques de terrorisme ou
d'atteinte grave à la sécurité des
personnes plusieurs amendements de notre
groupe ont été adoptés afin de mieux
encadrer le recours inédit à
l'intelligence artificielle en matière
de vidéo surveillance je salue
l'évolution dont tu as fait l'objet de
cette expérimentation et je soutiens le
choix du rapporteur sur la limitation de
l'expérimentation finalement prévu au 31
décembre 2024 au lieu de juin 2025
en commission mon groupe parlementaire a
aussi porté un amendement adopté afin
d'assurer une meilleure information
préalable du public entrant dans le
périmètre surveillé par des caméras
intelligentes il faut le reconnaître
c'est une garantie supplémentaire
contenue de l'importance du sujet nous
avons proposé la présence de
parlementaires de l'opposition dans le
cadre de l'évaluation de la mise en
œuvre de l'IA mesure adopter là aussi et
je m'en réjouis
un amendement trans partisan de notre
collègue Lopez ligori prévoit que le
tiers chargé du développement de l'IA
devra prioritairement être établi dans
l'Union européenne pour assurer la
protection de la sécurité nationale et
là aussi c'est une avancée s'agissant de
la lutte contre la fraude et les faux
billets les derniers événements sportifs
français notamment les incidents en
marge de la dernière finale de la Ligue
des champions de foot ont mis en exergue
la faiblesse de notre organisation notre
groupe salue les efforts introduits par
le Sénat pour renforcer le volet
prévention et appelle le gouvernement à
une grande vigilance et implication nous
soutenons également la création des
nouveaux délits d'intrusion et de
maintien illégaux dans des enceintes
sportives sur les seuls récidives et le
choix de la Commission de les recentrer
il s'agit d'une mesure en soi plus
proportionnelle enfin j'aurai quelques
mots pour nos forces de l'ordre
le rôle pour assurer la sécurité de
chacun va être de nouveau indispensable
il me semble que nous devons aussi tout
prévoir pour que ces femmes et ces
hommes sur le terrain puissent exercer
leur mission dans les meilleures
conditions ce texte qui nous est
présenté aujourd'hui va dans le bon sens
celui d'un encadrement démesure
sécuritaires et celui d'une recherche de
proportionnalité c'est pourquoi notre
groupe votre a majoritairement en faveur
de ce texte je vous remercie mon cher
collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas rudigos
pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente Madame la
Ministre des Sports des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mon cher Guillaume
vuitet heureux de vous revoir en forme
mes chers collègues nous arrivons au
terme d'un débat intense mais qui fut
majoritairement respectueux une
discussion qui permet à notre pays de se
tenir près à accueillir le plus grand
événement sportif jamais organisé en
France je le sais c'est quelque chose
que nous avons beaucoup répété mais
c'est comme si nous organisions 10 fois
la Coupe du Monde de 98 seulement sur
quelques semaines après les événements
de ces dernières années le débat
sécuritaire aura occupé une large place
dans nos débats je crois que nous avons
réussi à assurer le délicat équilibre
entre l'indispensable protection des
libertés publiques et l'absolu nécessité
d'assurer la sécurité des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques les
évolutions portées par cette assemblée
sont allés dans ce sens en préservant
les avancées obtenues en commission des
lois pour permettre l'expérimentation de
la vidéoprotection algorithmique dans
les meilleures conditions avec notamment
une fin de l'expérimentation ramenée au
31 décembre 2024 ou encore en autorisant
l'utilisation des scanners corporels
tout en s'assurant que l'information
soit complète et que l'intimité soit
préservée nous avons également avancé
grâce au président de la commission des
lois Sacha relier sur la question des
interdictions de stade pour tenir compte
notamment des contraintes
professionnelles et sociales des
personnes contraintes de pointer au
commissariat ou dans une gendarmerie
enfin ces jeux devant être les plus
inclusifs possibles nous avons rétabli
la rédaction de l'article 18 qui permet
qui permettra d'avoir jusqu'à 1000 taxis
supplémentaires réellement adapté aux
personnes en fauteuil roulant
par ailleurs mes chers collègues ces
débats nous aurons aussi permis de
définir une ligne claire entre ceux qui
veulent la réussite de ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et ceux qui
ne le souhaitent pas en vérité une ligne
claire entre ceux qui veulent mettre
tous les moyens pour assurer la sécurité
de l'événement et ceux qui pensent qu'on
pourrait finalement lésiner sur les
moyens pour accueillir juste le plus
grand événement sportif du monde et
démontre ainsi leur absence totale de
sens des responsabilités on a donc
parfaitement compris que les députés les
députés écologistes et insoumis voulait
tout mettre en oeuvre contre cette loi
était finalement contre les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
pour les insoumis pour les insoumis
madame Simonin a d'ailleurs clairement
assumer leur des débats mon cher
collègue si vous aviez été là elle l'a
dit elle était contre ces Jeux
Olympiques à Paris de notre côté depuis
Lima en septembre 2017 où la candidature
de Paris a été retenue par le CIO
jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous souhaitons tout
faire pour que la France organise dans
les meilleures conditions ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et que cette
fête populaire sportive soit un immense
succès
enfin mes chers collègues je tenais à
vous remercier Madame la Ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques et ainsi que Monsieur Miss
de l'intérieur pour la qualité des
échanges que nous avons eu et l'avant la
volonté d'avancer avec le Parlement dans
la construction de ce texte et plusieurs
collègues de l'opposition et de la
majorité l'ont rappelé madame la
ministre sachez que nous avons été
nombreux et quasiment sur tous les bancs
à apprécier votre engagement votre
écoute et aussi votre esprit de
compétition pour faire aboutir ce texte
et ainsi la réussite des géo des Jeux
olympiques de Paris enfin pour terminer
mes chers collègues ces jeux ce ne sera
pas simplement les jeux de Paris mais
ceux de tout le pays de Lyon à Tahiti en
passant par Marseille Mayotte que ce
soit par le passage de la flamme le
label terre des jeux ou l'accueil des
épreuves c'est la France tout entière
qui s'engage pour cette fête universelle
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris sont une occasion unique de
célébrer les valeurs du sport tels que
l'excellence le respect l'amitié mais
aussi la solidarité et la diversité ces
valeurs mes chers collègues nous avons à
partage en France un pays ouvert au
monde attaché au droit de l'homme à la
culture et au sport en cohérence le
groupe Renaissance votera bien
évidemment pour ce projet de loi je vous
remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Jordan Guitton
pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame monsieur les rapporteurs
chers collègues je voudrais rendre
hommage avant tout propos au travail de
nos forces de l'ordre qui servent chaque
jour dans un climat hostile et regretter
l'absence aujourd'hui du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui s'absente
malheureusement sur un texte pourtant
qui porte sur la sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques
130 ans après que ces jeux soient
réhabilités par la France nous avons
l'honneur d'accueillir les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 cet
événement mondial nous honore et nous
oblige mais malheureusement ce texte
souligne l'impréparation dans laquelle
est emprisé votre gouvernement pour
organiser ses Jo ce projet de loi
comporte des dispositions qui dépassent
largement les Jeux Olympiques et comme
vous n'assumez pas une politique un peu
sécuritaire que vous venez piocher dans
le programme du RN par moment vous vous
servez des Jeux Olympiques comme
prétexte vous justifiez l'utilisation
des caméras algorithmiques pour ne pas
renouveler le fiasco du Stade de France
de l'année dernière il faut le dire et
donc vous reprenez l'une des
recommandations du rapport sénatorial
mais ce que notifié ce rapport ainsi que
celui de l'UEFA ce sont les défaillances
de la gestion sécuritaire et les
mensonges concernant les supporters
anglais voici l'une des conclusions du
rapport que je cite les premières
déclarations ne correspondaient pas la
vérité ce sont celles de Monsieur
Darmanin et bien sûr l'intelligence
artificielle ne peut pas remplacer la
volonté politique si vous ne changez pas
de chef ni de méthode nous aurons
malheureusement les mêmes situations
catastrophiques qu'au stade de France
car les mêmes causes produisent toujours
les mêmes effets ce ne sont pas les
caméras algorithmiques qui changeront la
main tremblante de votre gouvernement ou
même les positions laxistes du garde des
sceaux tout au long du texte le groupe
rassemblement national vous a proposé
des modifications de bon sens et dans un
esprit constructif
réintégrer les soignants nos vaccinés
lors des Jeux olympiques pour éviter les
manques de personnels dans le reste de
la France vous l'avez refusé
garantir l'accès aux axes routiers pour
ceux qui vont travailler chaque jour
durant ces JO vous l'avez rejeté
augmenter les peines et mettre en place
des amendes forfaitaire délictuelles
dissuasives pour sanctionner rapidement
et fermement ce qui pénètre rond sans
billets dans les stades vous l'avez
aussi refusé limité enfin les caméras
algorithmiques aux Jeux Olympiques afin
de s'assurer de leur efficacité à
protéger les Français vous l'avez rejeté
et toutes nos interrogations qui restent
sans réponse quid de la cybersécurité
quid de la sécurité privée avec des
formations hyper accélérées quid de
toutes ces expérimentations pour les
Jeux Olympiques comme la radio du futur
ou les caméras algorithmiques malgré
votre opposition à nos propositions de
bon sens je tiens ici à remercier les
députés qui ont proposé des amendements
trop spartisans notamment sur la
sécurité des données qui seront stockées
à minimum en Europe protégez les
intérêts des Français en l'occurrence
leurs données et plus importants que les
intérêts de boutiquier de la nupes qui
n'agissent pas dans l'intérêt des
Français incapable de reconnaître et de
voter les bonnes idées des autres
groupes et d'ailleurs nous nous fierons
toujours comme les Français d'ailleurs
des paroles du ministre du ministre de
l'Intérieur je cite la France est prête
pour la visite du roi Charles III
déclarait-il la semaine dernière nous en
avons vu ce qu'il en était lundi La
France est-Elle prête pour accueillir
les Jeux olympiques et donc des millions
de visiteurs à l'instinct de la visite
du roi Charles III à l'instar du Stade
de France je vais vous le dire la seule
chose que vous avez accueilli c'est le
bateau de migrants ancienne Viking et
certains mineurs se sont même échappés
on comprend on comprend par cette loi
sur les jeux olympiques que lorsque nous
avons adopté la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur elle était
presque destinée uniquement elle aussi
pour les Jeux Olympiques en dehors des
200 brigades de gendarmerie si votre
intérêt sécurité légèrement ressuscité
après 5 ans de non-action lors de votre
premier mandat les tétons pour la
sécurité des Français au quotidien nous
n'en serions pas là en 2023 vous faites
preuve dans votre préparation des Jeux
olympiques de bien des incohérences et
les députés que nous sommes le
ressentent vous faites comme si la
France se portait bien aussi bien en
termes économique que sociaux mais les
Français ressentent l'inverse vous
faites fine oublier que le nombre
d'agressions par jour a été multiplié
par 7 depuis les années 80 mais les
Français eux le ressentent vous faites
comme si la politique d'immigration les
50 dernières années étaient sans
bouleversement mais les Français eux le
ressentent vous faites comme si le
gouvernement votre gouvernement n'avait
pas failli être censuré à neuf fois prêt
les Français l'ont bien vu et donc nous
voterons nous voterons pour ce texte
sans grande pertinence mais avec une
grande méfiance car il en va de
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation et des
Français d'accueillir ces Jeux
Olympiques dans de bonnes conditions ce
vote nous l'avons choisi non pas pour
vous le gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron
mais pour les français pour les Jeux
Olympiques car chez eux car ces Jeux
Olympiques auront une fin programmé en
2024 comme celle de votre majorité
d'ailleurs qui est programmé pour 2027
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Elisa Martin pour
la France insoumise
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente donc
700 amendements 50 acceptés
dont 19 du rapporteur que je salue à
l'essentiel à caractère rédactionnel
tout est dit dans cette affaire-là la
loi autre disposition et j'opte et la
loi des fins de non-recevoir la VSA est
dangereuse vous dit-on elle compromet
nos libertés fondamentales celles
d'aller à venir celle du respect de
notre vie privée celle de l'expression
Pacifique d'une opinion vous répondez
vous n'aimez pas la technologie
sincèrement à ce moment du débat nous
avons touché le fond pourtant
sommes-nous seuls à penser de cette
façon et bien non je pourrais citer
Amnesty internationale la Ligue des
droits de l'Homme la Quadrature du Net
le Conseil National des Barreaux le haut
nécessaire des Nations Unies au droit de
l'homme l'Union européenne que fort
malhonnêtement vous cherchez à prendre
de vitesse craignant qu'à l'interdise la
vidéo surveillance algorithmique aux
associations vous dites vous ne savez
pas lire bon il est elle apprécieront à
nous vous dites vous n'avez pas compris
c'est l'être humain qui déclenchera
l'opération ce à quoi nous répondons
encore heureux et d'ailleurs là n'est
pas le sujet ce dont le pays a besoin
cette présence humaine d'une police
respectée bienveillante au milieu des
habitants bien formés bien traité et non
pas épuisé n'est-ce pas appuyez sur une
déontologie solide à cela vous répondez
vous n'aimez pas la police
révèle en par la même la vacuité des
propos en l'occurrence du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui n'est pas là à nouveau
si la pétition demandant la dissolution
des équipes de braves m connaît un tel
succès comme je le disais la semaine
dernière c'est parce que les Français ne
veulent pas de cette police elle les
effraie tout simplement arrêt immédiat
de toutes les violences policières comme
le disait Léo Walter la semaine dernière
aussi les jobs ne peuvent pas être
prétextes ou tout sécurité car outre la
vidéo surveillance algorithmique nous
allons donc avoir droit au scanner
corporel à 11 millimétrique à
l'équivalent de la population parisienne
passée au crible passer au crible des
enquêtes administratives de sécurité
criminalisation il y a pas d'autres
termes des militants et supporters dans
les stades les jobs ne peuvent pas être
prétexte à à mesure antisociales je
pense évidemment à la généralisation
massive du travail le dimanche à des
mesures anti-écolo comme la promotion de
la consommation à tout va à cela vous
répondez vous n'aimez pas les JO ce que
vous ne pouvez obtenir par l'adhésion
vous l'obtenez par le mépris la force et
la violence comme pour les retraites
93% des actifs ils sont opposés 70% de
la population peu importe on y va on
s'impose ou alors ce qui s'est passé
Hassan ce week-end 4000 grenades en deux
heures en gros une toutes les deux
secondes si le ministre de l'Intérieur
qui n'est pas là avait été là je lui
aurais dit mais avez-vous perdu la tête
avez-vous perdu la tête trois morts
trois situations de personnes qui sont
entre la vie et la mort quel gâchis
pourquoi avez-vous interdit cette
manifestation vous bloquez toutes les
issues
tout compromis il faudra faire la
lumière sur ces événements il y aura une
enquête parlementaire et alors il faudra
s'expliquer avec précision sur qui et
comment cette violence a été commandée
vous nous avez beaucoup brocardé vous
nous avez beaucoup brocardé à nous de le
faire et à nous de le dire vous n'aimez
pas le pays vous n'aimez pas le peuple
dont vous avez peur et croyez-moi il
vous le rend bien nous voterons contre
ce texte de loi
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Maxime minot
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
et Messieurs les présidents de
commission Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
c'est le succès de ce grand événement
que nous visons tous certains n'y
étaient pas favorables mais maintenant
qu'ils approchent il est de notre
responsabilité collective d'en faire la
plus grande réussite possible
il nous faut préparer tous les aspects
de l'organisation de ces jeux a commencé
par la sécurité avec près de 7 millions
de spectateurs attendus sur toute la
durée des séjours les forces de l'ordre
et de secours doivent être au
rendez-vous le chapitre premier qui
traite de la création de la polyclinique
de la formation premiers secours et de
l'extension de la dérogation pour les
médecins étrangers est indispensable
nous saluons l'adoption en séance de
l'intégration à ce dispositif d'une
campagne de prévention des violences
sexistes et sexuelles sur les sites des
villages des athlètes et des médias ce
sujet malheureusement encore bien trop
souvent présent dans l'actualité
notamment dans le monde du sport doit
être au cœur de toutes les vigilances
durant l'événement mais ce qui inquiète
bien nombre de citoyens c'est leur
sécurité celles des sites des rues de
Paris et bien évidemment des transports
la cérémonie d'ouverture est un
challenge à elle seule avec 600 000
spectateurs attendus sa sécurisation est
un impératif si de nombreuses pistes ont
déjà été dessinées par le préfet de
police et le ministre de l'Intérieur à
ce sujet force est de constater qu'il
reste encore de nombreuses
interrogations qu'il faudra rapidement
solutionner
durant ces semaines de compétition nos
forces de l'ordre doivent être préparées
en nombre suffisants et armés des bons
outils pour lutter à la fois contre la
délinquance protéger les sites de
compétition et intervenir en cas de
nécessité nous ne pouvons nous retrouver
et dépasser par la situation à l'heure
où le monde aura les yeux rivés sur nous
c'est de la responsabilité de l'État et
du Kojo de maintenir une protection de
tout instant de tous les spectateurs
habitants d'Île-de-France et touristes
face à cette impératif des craintes
existent encore notamment en ce qui
concerne la protection privée et les
appels d'offres établis par le cojou
si les filières du secteur ont voulu
être rassurantes notamment lors de nos
échanges dans le cadre du groupe de
travail sur les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques les acteurs eux sont
encore inquiets nous savons la
préfecture d'Île-de-France Pôle emploi
et le ministère de l'Intérieur
pleinement mobilisé sur ce sujet et nous
espérons obtenir des garanties
rapidement les forces de l'ordre et
l'armée quant à elles vont être
grandement sollicités par ce grand
événement la solution était pourtant
toute trouvée et tendre le nombre de
jours autorisés d'activités au sein des
réserves du ministère de l'Intérieur et
de la police nationale à 45 jours pour
tous les fonctionnaires réservistes
enfin l'amendement que je portais a été
déclarée et recevable car hors sujet et
pourtant co-écrit avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur hors sujet dans un texte qui
pourtant est en les outils et les moyens
donnés aux forces de l'ordre et au
préfet de police
on aura tout vu c'est dommage puisque
l'objectif de ce texte ne devait pas de
créer des dispositions visant à mieux
garantir la sécurité alors effectivement
je ne peux cacher ma stupéfaction et
mettre déception mais j'ai de ce fait
d'ores et déjà déposer une PPL sur ce
sujet pour réparer ce quoi que
injustifié
concernant l'article 7 les débats ont
été mouvementés à juste titre et nous
entendons parfaitement les craintes
émises depuis certains bancs sur les
débardements juridiques en matière de
liberté individuelle que ces extensions
pourraient bien évidemment entraîner
au sein de notre famille politique nous
avons toujours été favorable à
l'utilisation des moyens technologiques
pour renforcer la sécurité dans notre
pays les forces de l'ordre ne peuvent
agir sans soutien et encore moins dans
un contexte aussi exceptionnel que la
tenue des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques d'ailleurs d'autres
dispositions ont été discutées comme le
sujet du dopage mais le dernier enjeu
qui nous semble être périlleux et celui
du transport nous en avons peu parlé car
le contenu du texte nous le permettait
pas mais nous avons réussi
collectivement à appuyer les évolutions
concernant l'accès aux personnes en
situation de handicap être le plus
inclusif possible voilà ce que nous
avions promis dans cette candidature le
développement de la flotte pour les
personnes en fauteuil inclus dans ce
texte était une nécessité mais nous
profitons de cette tribune pour lancer
une dernière alerte plus générale sur le
sujet des transports vélo voiture
transport en commun tout doit être
millimétré tous ces dispositifs ne
peuvent ne poursuivent qu'un seul but la
réussite de ces jeux et l'héritage qui
laisseront
sobriété budgétique budgétaire pardon
énergétique sécurité transport réussite
des athlètes ruissellement sur les
collectivités territoriales sur le sport
amateur bref la mission est grande au
sein des républicains nous sommes de
fervent défenseur de tout événement
fédérateur qu'importe l'ampleur de la
tâche nos pays à sérieusement besoin
aujourd'hui plus que jamais à nous
d'être d'en être à la hauteur et c'est
pourquoi nous voterons pour ce projet de
loi pour enfin ouvrir grand les jeux je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue je vous indique que je fais
annoncer le scrutin dans l'ensemble de
l'Assemblée nationale la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe la tombe pour le
groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le rapporteur vuetais heureux
de vous voir en forme mes chers
collègues après de nombreuses heures de
débats dans un climat relativement
apaisé nous voilà arrivés au terme de
l'examen du pglo
permettez-moi avant tout de saluer
l'écoute active des différents
ministères en particulier des sports et
de l'intérieur je salue également
l'ensemble des rapporteurs qui savamment
accompagner par leurs administrateurs
ont fourni un travail remarquable enfin
notre assemblée qui a su montrer sa
capacité à co-construire de façon
responsable et permis ainsi d'aboutir un
texte qui répond à quatre exigences
essentielles il est en effet ambitieux
précis équilibré et quoi qu'en disent
certains protecteurs des libertés
individuelles ambitieux car il permettra
rappelons-le à plus de 14850 athlètes de
passer leurs épreuves dans un cadre
soucieux de leur garantir une offre de
soins opérationnels il assura aussi la
sécurité des visiteurs des spectateurs
précis avec par exemple la lutte contre
le dopage grâce à la mise en conformité
du dispositif avec les recommandations
du Comité international olympique et
équilibrer protecteur car ce texte que
nous apprêtons à voter à l'unanimité
José espéré garantit à l'ensemble des
institutions politiques et à nos
autorités administratives indépendantes
le respect des libertés individuelles
afin d'assurer la sécurité des jeux pour
les athlètes et pour les spectateurs
venus des quatre coins du monde
en effet à la fois vitrine pour la
France est faite mondiale les prochains
jeux olympiques et paralympiques sont
c'est une évidence une chance pour notre
pays c'est aussi une obligation de
réussite tant en ce qui concerne
l'organisation que la sécurité de tous
nous n'avons donc pas le droit à
l'erreur
cependant à aucun moment l'impératif de
sécurité ne peut justifier la tentation
du solutionnisme technologique le
dispositif de sécurité reste l'un des
outils de cette réussite et ne doit en
aucune façon de venir une occasion de
malmener ou d'ébranler les fondements de
notre démocratie nous avons souhaité
préserver au maximum les libertés
individuelles et publiques nous pouvons
affirmer avec humilité que nous sommes
parvenus à cet objectif le groupe
démocrate a pris toute sa place dans ce
projet de loi pour permettre une
adéquation optimale entre sécurité et
liberté l'adoption de nos amendements
consacrons le rôle pivot de la CNIL en
est une illustration cette dernière aura
toute sa partition à jouer tout au long
de l'édiction de l'édiction des décrets
rappelons-le à nouveau la vidéo
surveillance algorithmique n'est pas
cette épouvantail caricatural que
d'aucun exhib en permanence parfois par
méconnaissance des possibilités
technologiques à notre service au groupe
démocrate nous sommes favorables à son
usage dès l'instant qu'il s'agit d'une
expérience bornée à la fois dans le
temps et dans l'espace un texte a duré
déterminé en quelque sorte proportionnée
aux enjeux et réserver à des conditions
et des circonstances parfaitement
identifiées c'est pourquoi nous nous
réjouissons de la modification opérée
s'agissant de l'expérimentation laquelle
sera des zones dorénavant bornée au 31
décembre 2024 au lieu de 30 juin 2025
initialement prévu marc-one volonté
commune et consensuelle cela mérite
d'être souligné de limiter cette
dernière au strict nécessaire le temps
consacré à l'analyse et aux leçons à
tirer de cette expérimentation à grande
échelle est ainsi significativement
bornée
nous nous réjouissons par ailleurs qu'à
l'occasion des débats le gouvernement
est su levé certains doutes et ainsi
parfaire et nourrir sa doctrine pour la
rédaction des futurs décrets
d'application afin que ces derniers
soient claires explicitent sans
ambiguïté ou contradiction pouvant
laisser libre cours à l'interprétation
par ceux qui devront les appliquer à
titre d'exemple la captation du son a
été écartée et ce choix validé par le
gouvernement il s'agit là d'une
illustration même du soin apporté à la
préservation des libertés individuelles
enfin tout en étant convaincu que les
décrets d'applications ne seront pas
remis en cause en question quand ils
seront examinés de près par le Conseil
constitutionnel et la CNIL je renouvelle
ma proposition madame la ministre nous
trouverions en effet de bonne politique
de déférer en urgence ce texte au
Conseil constitutionnel en amont de sa
promulgation dans une démarche de
transparence du législateur afin
d'éviter comme d'aucun envisage déjà de
le faire le dépôt de QPC qui Ré à
l'encontre de l'effectivité des
dispositifs et pourrait infiner en
retardant la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif nuire à l'objectif qui
justifie ce projet de loi celui
d'assurer dans les délais la sécurité et
le bon déroulement des jeux je crains en
effet madame la ministre qu'à l'issue
des débats qui ont lieu certains doutes
demeurent et bien que le climat est bien
que le climat des discussions étaient
constructif se déferment pourrait donc
contribuer à les dissiper reste que nous
nous réjouissons de la notion future de
ce texte ambitieux et protecteur et pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons nous le
voterons sans aucune réserve je vous
remercie
je vous remercie mes chers collègues
et pour terminer la parole est à
Monsieur Roger Vico pour le groupe
socialiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
texte important que ce texte madame la
ministre sur les Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique puisque il s'agit d'un
événement absolument exceptionnel dans
l'histoire d'ailleurs les Jeux
Olympiques ont pris une importance telle
qu'aujourd'hui
tel que aujourd'hui la totalité des
nations ou presque sont représentées
lors de cette manifestation avec des
défis qui se sont
amplifiés dans l'histoire les défis de
boycott parfois les défis du dopage
souvent hélas les deux filles de la
corruption aussi parfois les défis du
terrorisme le tout sous une exposition
médiatique maximum
pendant quelques semaines notre pays va
concentrer
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues on
écoute le dernier orateur je vous
demande de reprendre regagner vos places
dans le silence merci beaucoup allez-y
pendant quelques semaines donc notre
pays va concentrer les regards de 4
milliards de téléspectateurs et si nous
y arrivons si nous ne pouvons si nous
voulons nous pouvons faire de ces Jeux
Olympiques le vecteur magique de valeur
magnifique
je l'ai dit à plusieurs reprises au
moment des débats bien entendu nous
soutenons l'organisation de ces Jeux
Olympiques et bien entendu s'agissant
d'une manifestation exceptionnelle nous
soutenons évidemment l'idée qu'elle
fasse l'objet de moyens et d'une
organisation exceptionnelle
c'est pas la meilleure place la dernière
orateur je le crame
pour nickel merci de j'ai cru que j'ai
cru que l'Assemblée nationale se
remplissait à l'occasion de mon
intervention mais j'ai peur que
j'ai peur de mettre fait quelques
illusions on a le président
pendant tous ces débats nos amendements
monsieur le rapporteur vous pouvez en
témoigner je crois ne fait que tenter
d'améliorer et encadrer les dispositions
que vous proposez dans ce projet de loi
mais ils nous sont nés en moins que ce
texte est à la fois un cheval de Troie
ça a été dit mais aussi
mais aussi
mais aussi développe la stratégie de
l'hypnose que visiblement je ne suis pas
en capacité de développer moi-même à
l'instant présent
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
allez-y merci madame la Présidente
stratégie du cheval de Troie parce que
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises ce
texte est bien davantage un texte sur
des questions de sécurité qu'un texte
exclusivement sur les Jeux Olympiques
c'est surtout un texte sur la sécurité
après les Jeux Olympiques et sous
certains aspects nous Vous demandez une
sorte de chèque en blanc ce qui nous a
beaucoup gêné ce que nous avons tenté
d'améliorer à la faveur de nos
amendements il reste un certain nombre
de doutes sur ce texte notamment sur le
couplage entre la vidéo surveillance et
les algorithmes il est là le chef en
blanc puisque à aucun moment nous
l'avons finalement réussi à savoir ce
que seront ces algorithmes ce qu'il
détecteront comment ils seront formulés
puisque vous nous avez sans cesse
renvoyé à un futur décret dont nous ne
savons rien pour le moment il reste des
doutes bien entendu aussi autour du
scanner corporel à ondes millimétrique
et là madame la ministre je me permets
de
je me permets de vous rappeler la
dernière séance jeudi soir tardivement
où je vous ai posé deux fois la question
sur le gap terrible qui existe entre les
photos extrêmement rassurantes qu'on
nous qu'on nous a transmise
de ce que sont ces scanners en
millimétriques et les textes qui
indiquent que le caractère
particulièrement intrusif de ces
scanners nécessité de flouter au maximum
ou plutôt un minima les visages et à
plusieurs reprises je vous ai posé la
question à plusieurs reprises je n'ai
pas eu de réponse et puis les craintes
également les craintes également sur les
amendements qui avaient déposé mon
camarade Jérôme Guedj sur les
dérogations au principe du repos
dominical dont nous craignons bien
entendu que là aussi il soit généralisé
par la suite
néanmoins
néanmoins nous avons
consulté nos amis qui sont impliqués
dans l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
je pense à nos camarades du département
de Seine-Saint-Denis je pense bien
entendu à nos amis de la Mairie de Paris
nous avons consulté nous avons discuté
nous avons échangé les arguments où nous
avons évalué et infinés infinie nous
avons décidé en conscience de nous
abstenir sur ce texte qui sera qui sera
une abstention vigilante merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue
donc je vais maintenant mettre voir le
projet de loi tout le monde a bien pu
regagner sa place le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 547
exprimé 493 majorité 247 pour 400 contre
93 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés au
terme de ce débat fructueux
utile riche je voudrais vraiment saluer
l'adoption par l'Assemblée nationale de
ce projet de loi portant sur les jeux
c'est une étape essentielle que vous
nous permettez ainsi de franchir je
voudrais adresser tout particulièrement
mes remerciements au rapporteurs
Béatrice Bellamy Christine le nabot
Bertrand Sorg Guillaume viltest Stéphane
Mazar ainsi qu'aux président rapporteur
Sacha hullier à la présidente Isabelle
roche et aux membres des trois
commissions qui ont particulièrement
œuvré sur ce projet mais remerciements à
tous sur ces bancs aussi remerciements
auxquels je veux associer le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer ainsi que
le ministre chargé des transports qui
montent accompagné dans la conception et
dans le portage politique de ce texte
j'ai vraiment apprécié je voulais vous
le dire la qualité la franchise de nos
échanges mais également l'écoute
l'exigence dont vous avez fait preuve
pour améliorer ce texte en commission
comme en séance publique
amendement au total porté par les
députés en commission ou en séance dont
près d'une trentaine
issue des groupes de l'opposition
ensemble oui nous l'avons amélioré ce
texte règle antidopage complète en
Polynésie garantie renforcé sur la
vidéoprotection garantie aussi monsieur
Vico renforcé sur les scanners corporels
dont je vous promets qu'ils seront
pleinement protecteurs de la vie privée
meilleure équilibre dans la lutte contre
toutes les formes d'incivilités et de
violence dans le stade à la suite des
événements du Stade de France nous
devions en tirer les leçons visibilité
supplémentaire madame Bellamy octroyer
aussi à notre cher coupe du monde de
rugby attention portée aux enjeux
d'accessibilité dans la polyclinique de
sensibilisation handicap prévention des
violences à caractère sexistes ou
sexuels au cœur du village olympique au
cœur du village des médias et aussi
conciliation des intérêts de chacun dans
l'ouverture d'un certain nombre de
commerce pendant quelques semaines
autour des jeux le dimanche souci
d'équilibre soucis permanent de
protection des droits et libertés de nos
concitoyens cette soucis d'équilibre je
forme le vœu que il soit poursuivi qu'il
se finalise dans la poursuite de nos
travaux de votre travaux en CMP et j'ai
vraiment à cœur de continuer à pouvoir
vous rendre compte sur l'avancée de
notre préparation en vue de ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques en lien avec
le groupe de suivi sur les jeux en lien
aussi avec la mission parlementaire sur
les retombées économiques et sociales
des jeux ensemble
on va faire de ces jeux un succès pour
notre pays et motif de bonheur et de
fierté pour les Français merci encore à
tous merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la séance est suspendue
[Applaudissements]